♪ [upbeat music plays]
Ralf Knoesel: At VectorUnit,
we make video games.
So, our background is
in console games,
so that the last game we made
was a game for Xbox Live Arcade.
And now, earlier this year,
we basically figured out,
"OK. Where's the console
space headed?"
And we're seeing tablets and phones.
It's kind of moving into that space.
And so, we, we thought this was a pretty
good time for us to make the mobile game.
And the Android platform seemed like
a really good opportunity for that.
So basically, what we're able
to do this year
that would've been impossible
about a year ago,
is we're taking our engine,
which is a console engine,
which runs on C, C++,
and we're able to pretty much port it
straight over to the Android platform,
using the native STK.
And so the game we're showing
today is called Riptide GP.
It's basically what we consider
sort of a console-quality game
running on a mobile device.
And so, yeah.
We're able to get all these effects
and great-looking art assets,
onto the platform using the Google Tools.
A lot of people, I think, shy away
from the mobile platforms
because the assumption is
there's so little power there
and it's also really hard to do TOCOAN on it.
But from our perspective,
it only took us about two to three weeks
to take our console-quality engine
and get it up and running on,
on the Android platform.
And so, right now we're placing a foundation
and we definitely see it in the next year or two.
It's not gonna slow down.
We think it's gonna accelerate,
the number of devices out there.
So, we think with the Android platform
we'll definitely be able to reach
the most number of consumers.
00:01:24.583,00:00:00.000